("Doo Wop" by J.I.D)
- [Gary] Yeah, good so
far in L.A., big day.
Big promotion day
for Planet of the Apps
later with a
little bit of a party.
And you're gonna get
some real footage there, huh?
Did you get
clearance to be there?
That'll be interesting.
Anyway, grinding,
grinding, grinding,
grinding, grinding, grinding.
("Where Im Going" by Jerry Folk)
- Why is there so little
energy around creating new IP?
Is it 'cause the studios don't
have appetite to take the risk?
The economics are so much
more fun with guaranteed--
- [Man] The studios have IP
that we could exploit,
but that's a good
spot for them to work.
And...
- But everybody's
just rebooting right?
It's just good ROI, right?
- [Man] Yeah, and so for them
it's a good business to just...
("Where Im Going" by Jerry Folk)
- Perfection is poison.
It's just another
fucking excuse for not doing.
So many of you are using
it as a high-brow excuse.
Everybody's always
trying to tell people
why they can't
or why they aren't.
Like excuses man,
it's fucking poison.
I fucking hate excuses.
Prefer people that use
like bullshit one's like
Uh, I grew up in
a bad neighborhood.
The perfection one
really fucking pisses me off.
'Cause people think they're
being clever and hiding it.
Oh, I'm a perfectionist,
I do it right.
You don't do it right, Dick.
You're not doing it at all.
That's the problem, you're
doing it right theoretically
so often you
never put anything out.
You know what's subjective?
Everything,
everything is subjective.
Your song, your video,
your social media posts,
your business idea,
all subjective.
You know what's not subjective?
Putting it out on
time, putting it out.
You know what's not subjective?
12:05 Eastern P.M.,
Tyler.
That's not subjective.
You know what's not subjective?
When you fucking grind
on your flight out here
and get my inbox from 300
things I have to do to 84.
Not subjective.
What was subjective
was should it been 86
or should it been 82?
That's where you
had to make a call.
People are crippled
to not make calls.
So, they don't
end up doing anything.
And then all you fuckers who
use perfection as a disguise,
you think you're
smarter than everybody.
You may be
tricking the losing players,
but the winning
players see right through you.
(DRock inaudible)
I'm mad about
this perfection thing.
I see it at VaynerMedia,
I see it with
my business partners,
I see it with my start,
no, no, no,
it's gotta be perfect.
I'm so close to
having it perfect.
No you're not, you just
don't want to get it done.
I don't like high-brow excuses.
I like low-brow excuses.
I like people, I like
that dude the other day
at Washington Park who's like
"I'm just watching Netflix bro."
That's honest.
Somebody who's
like, "Oh you know,
"I need to be inspired
to get it exactly right
"'cause if I get it
right it will win."
Just that stuff is like,
"Or you don't get
it" like "I'm an artist.
"This is gonna
be real right soon.
"I just need to..."
Shit, fuck that shit.
("Doo Wop" by J.I.D)
- How you doing, man?
- Man, good. How about yourself?
- Real good.
- Big shout out
to you real quick,
because that day
you posted my song man
I got so many people
scoop my song off iTunes.
So, shout out to you for that.
Man, you stay on a plane, bro.
Every time I see
you you on a plane.
- I live at the airport.
So what's been going
on man, how's it going?
- Honestly, I've
just been grinding.
You know, like
really smashing it.
Just drop,
after drop, after drop.
And each time I drop something,
I mean I can see
the numbers go up.
So, you know, the consistency
it kinda feeds my--
- How often, once a week,
once every two weeks?
- Last week
I dropped three songs.
- Last week?
- Yeah, last week
I dropped three songs.
A week before that
I dropped two songs.
And it's usually
one a week, but I just,
I'm just really
trying to pump 'em.
Like I'm trying to make
sure that something--
- Is your mind in the
place where I'm at which is,
it's just a matter of time.
It's literally just once--
- 100 percent.
- Like the reason you
want to drop two or three is
it gives you more
chance for have that song
that changes everything.
- Exactly. Exactly, it's--
- It's a numbers game.
- Yo it really is, it
really is a numbers game.
- I believe that man.
- I genuinely believe it too.
I listen to your audiobook of,
the most recent
one what was that?
- #AskGaryVee.
- Yes, dude, yo and
this isn't to take any shots
because it's a bunch of
amazing factual information.
The biggest thing
I took out of that book
is pinpointing why I have been
so confident and successful
and it is because of
how my mom raised me.
And I was never able
to put my finger on that
until I saw you
say it in that book.
I was just like you know.
- That makes sense.
- It literally, thanks to my mom
I feel like I can do anything.
- It's the best.
- I feel like she pumped
me full of this confidence.
And I never pinpointed it--
- Did you call
her and say thanks?
- Yes I really did.
She's my reason for everything.
(DRock inaudible)
What was that?
("Where Im Going" by Jerry Folk)
- Heading over to film
a TV show called (censored).
Gonna teach the aspiring
(censored) how to use social media
for my homie (censored).
She's awesome.
This should be interesting.
Shhh.
("Doo Wop" by J.I.D)
Just filmed a quick little TV
cameo that I'm gonna be doing.
So you'll be seeing that.
I'm not even sure
if I can talk about it.
I'll hit up the peeps
and ask them if I can.
Anyway, just
business call, business call.
I've got an interesting meeting
with a holding company
conglomerate that owns brands
that could be for VaynerMedia,
could be for my
future ambitions.
Take a lot of meetings that
are not as black and white.
Way too many
people only take meetings
where they get
something out of it right away.
To me, I like
taking meetings that
could bring value
three, four, five,
six, seven years from now.
And if they do
bring value right away,
then Mazel Tov.
Driving my social.
Getting serious
about Snapchat again.
See a little opening there.
Work.
("Where Im Going" by Jerry Folk)
- [Woman] Thank you.
- How are you, man?
- Alright.
- You good?
- Super.
How is it?
- It's great to see ya.
Great.
-Africa.
- Amazing.
It's like, amazing.
- Dope.
- So amazing.
We gotta catch up
and talk about it.
Hey man, good to see ya.
- How are things?
- How are you?
- Good, great.
- I like the haircut, man.
- Yes!
- It's stylish I like it.
I like it.
How are you guys feeling?
- We're graduating next week.
- Congratulations, guys.
That's a big deal.
- Yeah.
- We should definitely catch up.
- That would be awesome.
- Feel free to reach out.
I'd love to hear from you.
- Definitely, we'll do that.
And we'll try not to hog you.
- No, I'm here for you guys.
Forever.
- You're so sweet, thank you.
- Awesome, sure thing, awesome.
("Doo Wop" by J.I.D)
So our commercial just aired.
My phone's blowing
up, so that's cool.
And let's see what,
let's see what the buzz is.
Jason, I will
never be big time, baby.
I'll always be a
boy from Belarus.
Appreciate the love.
I could swear I just heard
your voice in the NBA game.
You know, it's funny.
This is a really
interesting scene
because the
event's going on inside.
Everybody's
drinking a vodka martini
and I'm on Twitter
engaging with everybody
who just saw the commercial
during the NBA Finals.
It's just so fucking,
this right here is
the difference moment.
I'm not in it for
the glitz and the glamor.
I'm in it for the fucking,
the blood and the dirt.
Everybody can go party it up.
I'm fuckin' here workin'.
Okay.
It's still just a commercial.
Not that much chatter.
- [DRock] Really?
- Yep.
People don't get it, man
but let's not for this party.
- Who's that?
- It's me, it's GaryVee.
- What?
- I've heard of this guy.
- I'll teach you, Jess.
That's what I'm here for.
(upbeat music)
- [Woman] Terrible.
- [Man] Look handsome together.
- [Gwyneth] Alright, photos.
- Come here for a selfie.
Keavis, Get out of the photo.
- I didn't know.
- Alright.
- Is this a Snapchat?
- [Man] I kinda
wanna be in that picture.
- [Jessica] I'm the greatest.
- Jess, why are
you the greatest?
- 'Cause I was born that way.
- Born that way.
(laughing)
("Doo Wop" by J.I.D)